hello everyone I'm Dave Robinson chief
data scientist at data camp and I'm
gonna be sharing some advice on live
tweeting so when Jared challenged me to
give this talk about 40 minutes ago I
had started to think about what kind of
advice I might want to give to this
group about live tweeting and I'm able
to give not only advice but up-to-date
literature review about the best
practices for live tweeting so first the
advice is that Twitter is easier than it
looks
so usually people might be nervous you
might say I don't know what this Twitter
thing is what am I going to do with it
and then once you try it out you can
find it can be really fun really
rewarding and a great way to participate
in the conference with everyone else so
you just so I've had a lot of experience
live tweeting I found it a really great
way to keep track of what I've done in a
conference so for example in 2016 I went
to some conferences live tweeted them
and I was able to take those and
assemble them into a blog post that
makes me really happy that I was able to
keep track of these while I was going
and I'll share what I've learned first
always make sure you use the conference
hashtag so here that's hashtag our stats
NYC and that also lets you compete on
the leaderboards that they've been
showing off always at the speaker so
always include an act than the speakers
on screen I Twitter handle you'll notice
that in the program Jared has set up
that every speaker has their handle in
their description and always include a
picture this is a practice that I really
enjoy it's great especially great here
we you have these screens around you can
include a screen very close up of this
of the slide or you can include a screen
of the speaker and it's a really good
way to get people that aren't at the
conference to kind of feel like they're
there and it tends to get more
engagement they'll show some
quantitative evidence about that later
three things you could use to tweet
about one would be to introduce a person
or a topic so yesterday for example I
introduced when David Smith started
talking about Minecraft I tweeted to say
I'm really looking forward to this he's
combined are in Minecraft and give a
sense of what the talks about we can
spread one insight
talk like yesterday Noam Ross talked
about sharing data within our stats
package and I took a picture of that
slide and kind of passed those on so
people are that aren't at the conference
can understand a bit what he was
communicating or you can link to an
additional resource that the speaker
might want people to read this morning
Hadley gave a talk where he referred to
his chapter of advanced are on names and
values so I did a tweet that linked to
that and let's uh people that maybe are
either at the conference or following
along can understand a bit more of the
context around the talk and one last
piece of advice they have really seen
them done really well this year's show
off and by that I mean take something
you're talented at and use it to enhance
everyone's speak speaking understanding
so Brook Watson if you're not seeing
these tweets they're really fantastic
she's a talented artist and note taker
and she makes a little summary of each
combine with the profile of them and
they've been really fantastic way to
take something that she's talented at
and use it to enhance everyone's
experience to the conference so if
you're not following Brook Watson you
definitely should I just started
yesterday so that's some qualitative
advice but it's always important to take
a look at the literature in particular a
randomized experiment earlier I said
that it's better to include a picture
and gets more engagement but what does
the actual X I until a so to do that we
take a look at Robinson and Robinson
2018 where there were two tweets posted
it almost exactly the same time by two
tweeters where one of them didn't
include a picture and one of them did so
it turned out it but I went a bit
against the common consensus about
pictures because there was where 76
retweets on the one that didn't have a
picture and 64 on the one that did but
of course you can't just look at the
original experiment you need to look at
the following scholarly discourse in
this case we have a follow-up Robinson
2018 that pointed out that the original
did not use an appropriate normalization
metric and we should have normalized by
the number of followers it was followed
by a comment on Robinson 2018
along the lines of the fact that life
isn't fair and finally of course most
importantly we have peer review where
others that are involved in this space
are able to give their own opinion about
this discussion thank you
you